okay I'm Robert what's your name partner
what's your name talk to me
okay
okay listen we can work this out pardon
okay
I want to do is just get the people
outside please
[Applause]
we can work this out just let them
outside okay
[Applause]
[Music]
officials release dramatic body camera
footage of a deadly officer-involved
shooting at a hospital in Dallas Texas
foreign
[Music]
it happened on October 2nd at the
Methodist Dallas Medical Center
surveillance video shows the suspect
later identified as Nestor Hernandez
arriving at the hospital just before 10
30 that morning after that he enters the
mother and baby unit
[Music]
what happened
[Music]
you got emergency traffic investigators
say Hernandez entered a patient room
belonging to his girlfriend a newborn
baby he accused his girlfriend of
infidelity and then began acting violent
officials say Hernandez pulled a handgun
out of his pants and later hit his
girlfriend in the head multiple times
[Music]
[Applause]
Hernandez allegedly began firing
multiple shots one directed at Methodist
Medical system Sergeant Robert Rangel
two Hospital workers nurse Katie Annette
flowers and social worker Jacqueline
puka were shot and killed situations
Dallas officials say Sergeant Rangel
shot Hernandez in the leg as he was
reloading his weapon body camera video
then shows Sergeant Rangel trying to
convince Hernandez to come out of the
hospital room okay I'm Robert what's
your name partner what's your name talk
to me
okay okay
listen we can work this out partner okay
all I want to do is just get the people
outside please Sergeant Rangel calls to
Hernandez multiple times pleading for
him to give up the weapon
partner we can work this out man trust
me
[Music]
I had no idea bro I don't even know who
you are after that Sergeant Rangel
describes the suspect to responding
police officers
all I know is there's a female I believe
in a baby in size
no the male is a shooter Blackwater
Hispanic Hispanic about maybe five five
brought about 20 24 years of age
uh all I could see was a black pistol
you see it right now no no he walked in
the room I I actually he was coming out
I believe he had the gun in his hand I
shot one time and he went back in the
room throughout most of the incident
Hernandez's girlfriend can be heard
screaming hands up hands up in the air
hands up in the air please
throw that gun out come on man
the woman can be heard begging officers
not to shoot Hernandez please brother
I'm asking you come on
we have nothing to shoot him come up
with your hands up in the air
eventually officers convince Hernandez
to surrender
come out your hands up come on the
hallway
keep coming keep coming to the hallway I
need you in the hallway when Hernandez
leaves the room officers take him into
custody and perform first aid Hernandez
was taken to another hospital and
treated for his injuries he was charged
with capital murder and assault of a
public servant he's since been
transferred to the Dallas County Jail
the Dallas Police Department
investigation into the shooting is still
ongoing for the latest developments in
this story and all things True Crime
stay with long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie